WOJTEK KALICINSKI: We know
developers don't like standing
still and want access to the
latest and greatest features
in the tools they use, and that
includes programming languages.
With Android Studio
3.0, we're not only
shipping Kotlin as an official
new language for Android,
but we're also
making life easier
for those of you who prefer
to code in Java by introducing
support for Java 8 language
features in the default
toolchain.
Starting with the Android
Gradle plugin version 3,
you can freely use
lambdas, method references,
default and static interface
methods, try-with resources,
and repeating annotations
on all Android API levels.
If you previously switched to
using the experimental Jack
compiler to be able
to use these features,
please note that
there are now many
benefits when using
the default toolchain.
Jack offered more
restricted Java
8 support that worked
only for API 24 and above.
It wasn't as fast
when compiling code.
And it created problems for
developers using tools that
depend on the class format.
That's why we deprecated Jack
and will no longer support it
in Android Studio and tools.
The good news is that
switching back is very simple.
Just delete these lines
from your build file.
If you're using one of the
popular third-party solutions
for Java 8 language
features, you
might find that they lack
some of the functionality
of the default
toolchain, such as being
able to seamlessly process
libraries that use Java 8 code.
If you want to make
the switch, you'll
have to remove Retrolambda
or DexGuard from your build.
Otherwise, the built-in
support will remain disabled.
Other than that, make sure
you have the following lines
in build Gradle and that you are
using at least Android Gradle
plugin version 3.
For important plugin
migration instructions,
refer to our other video
or the documentation
linked in the description.
So now that you have
everything set up,
what can you actually do
with the new features?
Lambdas are a really
nice shorthand notation
for implementing functional
interfaces, or in other words,
interfaces that have
only one abstract method.
Many times when you pass
a Runnable or a listener
to another method, you need
all this boilerplate just
to run a few lines of code, when
all you could write is this.
Android Studio lets
you easily convert
between lambdas and
anonymous classes
so you can learn
the syntax quickly.
With method references
you can sometimes
even avoid creating
a lambda by directly
passing a method with a correct
signature as a parameter.
Use the double colon
syntax like this.
If you want to put utility
methods in your interfaces,
you can now do it
with a static keyword.
Moreover, you can have methods
with default implementations
that will not require you to
change any subclasses when you
add them to the base interface.
Try-with resources
is a great way
to deal with closable
resources, such as files.
Previously you had to be
extra careful to catch
exceptions and close any open
streams in a finally block.
Now when you declare a resource
in that try block opening
statement, it will be
automatically cleaned up
for you after that block exits.
The new language
features are provided
by transforming bytecode
into a representation
compatible with other
platforms, a step which
we called desugaring.
This is not a backport of
Java 8 packages, and as such,
many SDK restrictions still
apply for using newer APIs,
like java.lang.string,
in your code.
One last thing-- as part of
our continuing investment
into the toolchain
with Android Studio 3,
we're introducing
a new dexer called
D8 that is available
for you to preview.
Add this line in your
Gradle properties
file, and the build
process will use D8
for converting class
files to dex bytecode.
In our tests, D8
compiles faster,
and produces smaller
files, and can even
improve runtime performance.
As an app developer,
you shouldn't
have to make any changes to your
usual workflow when using D8.
However, tool developers
need to be aware
that D8 moves that desugar
step after any custom bytecode
transforms.
As such, your
transformation tools
might begin to see Java
8 bytecodes when using D8
and have to be made compatible.
So have fun writing
more expressive code.
And please let us know
on the bug tracker
if you run into any issues
when trying the new dexer.
And check out your videos about
Android Studio 3.0 features.
[MUSIC PLAYING]